Good morning John.
This is a QR code.
It's a way of visually representing data,
just like barcodes, or snapcodes, or facial
expressions, or the written word.
And I was looking at one of these things recently
and I thought to myself: how much data could
you really fit on a QR code?
Well, QR codes are complicated and I don't
have enough time to explain them in total.
But, suffice it to say that each block of
2 by 4 squares codes for one byte of data.
One character of text.
The question that I had was could you print
out all of Wikipedia on one QR code and have
a camera that could scan that code and you
could get all of Wikipedia by scanning one
QR code?
I'm aware that this is a dumb question, but
it very much is the type of dumb question
that I enjoy figuring out the answer to.
Just the text portion of just the English
portion of Wikipedia is about 24 terabytes.
That's 24 trillion bytes.
So in order to get the number of squares we
need, we just multiply that number by 8 because
it's eight squares per byte.
I don't want to know how many squares this
thing is gonna be, I wanna know how many squares
it's gonna be on each side.
So, we take the square root of that number.
To figure out how much space that will actually
take up, we have to figure out how big each
one of those tiny little blocks are.
I'm gonna say about 2 millimeters because
that's pretty easy to print and to read by
a QR reader.
So you multiply that number by two and then
convert from millimeters to kilometers and
there you have it, you have a QR code that's
just 27 kilometers on a side that has ALL
of Wikipedia on it.
Now, of course, this is just half the battle.
We've printed out Wikipedia on a 27 kilometer
by 27 kilometer sheet of paper, but we need
a camera that can actually do that.
Well, if you have a camera with a 90 degree
field of view, then you can take a picture
of this whole thing, you just have to be 13.5
kilometers away from it.
However, there's some bad news that comes
along with this.
First, at that distance, the atmosphere is
going to distort this image way too much,
so we've got to take it out of the atmosphere
and into space, put the QR code on the surface
of the moon and put the camera in orbit around
the moon at around 13.5 km up.
No big.
The second problem is actually a bigger problem
cuz it deals with you know, just sort of the
fundamental nature of the universe.
From so far away, and with blocks so tiny
to try and resolve, you run into what's called
the diffraction limit.
Basically, when passing through the aperture
of our camera, the difference between the
size of our aperture, that's the hole that
the light comes through, and the wavelength
of light is significant enough that it blurs
anything below a certain size.
So to take a picture of something so tiny
from so far away, you need to do one of two
things, or both of them.
One, make the aperture of the camera really
huge or two, make the wavelength of the light
smaller.
But if you want to take the picture of this
thing with a cell phone camera, you can as
long as your cell phone camera just happens
to be able to detect gamma rays.
Gamma rays are radiation with a very small
wavelength, also problematically with very
high energy, so it's difficult to print with
ink that would absorb gamma rays because they
would normally just fly right through it,
so you've gotta find some kind of really special
gamma ray absorbing ink.
The other, in my opinion better, solution
to this problem is to make your aperture just
huge and one way to do that is to just use
the James Webb space telescope which we're
already developing and has a pretty massive
aperture.
Now, you'd have to modify it so it could be
a wider-angle camera cuz it's a telescope
right, it's got telescopic, not a wide angle
lens.
But the James Webb space telescope does have
an aperture big enough that it could conceivably
resolve these two millimeter pixel things
from 13.5 kilometers away.
However, it does not have a sensor sensitive
enough to take a picture of all of them at
once, which I would like for it to do so that
we can just take a picture and real quick
have all of Wikipedia.
So we are going to have to develop a new camera
sensor that has like 10,000 times more pixel
resolution than the current highest in military
spy cameras that we use, but I have confidence
that we can do that in the intervening time
between when we are able to actually print
out all these pieces of paper, which is gonna
take some time, and get them to the moon and
lay them out in the proper order.
So the answer to the question "can you print
out Wikipedia and have it be a scannable QR
code?"
The answer is yes, not really with current
technology but it is possible.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
I want to end this video by saying you know,
I'm not entirely sure.
I could have got something wrong, and I want
to say thanks to Henry from MinutePhysics
for coming over and helping me with the math
of this.
That was a really enjoyable project.
That's my life.